you probably know this already but you can fast forward if you want to
so as you can see your pattern is scored based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your mark
as you can see it's split up into two parts we have our accuracy and our presentation on this
side so we'll start off with the accuracy first so i'll look at the pattern and then with that one
any mistakes that you make whether it's a minor mistake yes minus a zero it's a very very small
thing so say we're doing a outer block if it's not your shoulder height maybe it's a little bit
lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's so that would be a major mistake so with the minor
mistake uh let's say pattern one for example
there's uh 20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns
uh sorry the 20 steps so the reason for that one being uh it needs to be absolutely perfect to get
to not get a deduction of 0.1 leave that there on this side and we'll come back and we'll just
calculate the score at the end so maybe a mistake say you're supposed to turn to the left but you
turn to be here so with this one uh for a score of two is your power and speed your rhythm is also
a score of two and your expression of energy which is anything you are that you both so you do need
to kind of um work on your rhythm and that's also scored out for two uh the last bit is your
expression of energy so what is expression of energy and black belts it's actually scored a
little bit differently so if you're a color belt you'll actually score a little bit more than a
black belt if you are a black belt it's actually uh your average so where where the judges actually
mark you from uh okay let's say one of our ten so let's see and for presentation we have 0.7
one two three so you added 3.7 let's say you made 15 mistakes so with this one obviously
don't be too discouraged if you do get uh pretty high your mistakes
this is with the judges we have three judges usually at the panel if you're in
yellow or above and you do your patterns it's not uncommon it's actually
considered almost world-class so if you get a seven for any of your patterns you
generally need to pat yourself on the back you did an amazing job so with this
one takes out and then we average that as well so you hope this helped you guys
so make sure you enjoy your pool deck competition and anytime make sure obviously you
practice reading so I'm doing it on yeah here so minor errors major errors while
you're watching your video there's no pausing because I'm like a real judge
you can undo like yeah okay this is for the major and then right after the
performance you can read your power and speed coordination for them and
expression of energy when you're ready
you
Thank you.